currently all the list items have the
same layout however we want the today
item to use a different layout which we
defined earlier in the list item
forecast today XML file this is where
adapter item view types will save the
day this is a general concept for all
adapters not just cursor adapter instead
of just knowing about one item view type
which yields the same layout for all
list items the adapter can declare
multiple item view types so it will have
different list item layouts for a given
row in the cursor the forecast adapter
needs to decide if it should be a
regular list item or a today list item
then it will inflate and bind data for
the appropriate layout will jump into
the forecast adapter code now to learn
how to handle a second item view type
normally in the subclass get view type
count returns 1 but we're going to
override it so it returns two for the
two different layouts but how does it
know when to use one LAN or the other
well we override get item view type so
that when the position in the list is 0
then we say that it's the day view type
otherwise it's the future day view type
these two view types are declared up
above these are just integer
representations of the view type the
numbering has to start at 0 because
these values cannot be greater than or
equal to get view type count so the
possible values for us are 0 and 1 so
that we know that 0 always maps to the
view type today and that one always maps
to view type future day we're going to
use this information in the new view
method remember that previously we
inflated the list item forecast XML now
we're going to use the item view type to
determine whether we should use one
layout or the other
fill in the to do to address this
behavior layout' ID refers to resource
ID which is in the form of r dot layout
that's something